>> So, after that, I'm not actually talking
about anything technical so if you want you
can phase out now and have a rest. I'm actually
talking about a used case where in my day
job I'm the development coordinator for the
local government and Shires Association in
New South Wales. That's sort of a representative
body for all the councils in that state. And
I've been looking at how Wave can really assist
in this area because local government is one
of the textbook examples of where Wave could
really work. See, in local government, e-mail
is already king. Everything gets sent out,
everything gets tracked. All interaction with
the public is tracked, every phone call that
gets--every phone call that comes in is logged,
every e-mail that comes in gets added to the
document tracking system. Everything is tracked
so they also need to make sure that they know
who said what. In local government, as in
anything else public service, need to know
authoritativeness is paramount. You need to
know who said what, when, and why. I'm just
going to go through the different--a few different
used cases within a local government organization.
But generally it's we need to track everything.
Okay, the first used case is probably the
most public used case, it's the front desk.
This is an image I cut from my local council's
website. As you can see we got a whole range
of different things that we could be using
Wave for, contacting council, just general
inquiries, you know, "Where has my bin gone?
Can I--when's the next garbage run coming?"
Council runs a number of venues. They run
parks, they run dropping centers, a number
of things so if people want to book venues,
property certificates. Now, development applications
I deal with in a little bit later on the talk,
but all of these needs to be authoritative,
all of these needs to be tracked, and all
of these could really use Wave to do it. Okay,
the team that I work in at the moment is the
comms team for the LGSA. Now, they are constantly
collaborating or constantly having to work
together to create press releases, information
sheets and all the rest of it, but they're
having to use Outlook and they're having to
use e-mail to do it. Now, this is a pain in
the bum. Whereas a wave system, which allows
them to, you know, real time collaboration,
tracking when changes were made, tracking
when things were sent out without having to
troll back through, you know, half a dozen
folders would make--would be a really beneficial
systems for them. The other thing that it
allows them to do is to keep track of the
conversations with media people and others.
I mean, if they--if you make up the external
e-mail with an internal wave system, all of
a sudden every conversation you have with
a journalist can now be tracked in the wave
system so that someone else can come along
read the conversation in wave format, which
is a lot easier to read, and then if somebody
top posts, bottom posts, middle posts an e-mail
thread, and they can get on top of any problem
or any issue in a lot quicker and a lot easier.
Most comms team are small especially on local
governments. So they need to be able to get
in this--have this flexible way of moving
around things. Okay, one of the--see, I'm
coming at this from an Australian perspective
when it comes to local government. But I'm
pretty sure that even in America or anywhere
else, one of the main functions of local government
is assessing development within their area.
You would--you have to apply for building
permission, you have to apply for a number
of different things. Now, all of these--there
are a number of different systems in the councils
for tracking development applications. A lot
of them in Australia are starting to put developmental
applications online so people can see what's
happening. But what we need to do is we need
to keep everything in one thread. If we can
keep all the information, everything that's
said and everything that's noted about an
application, any changes that are made in
one thread, it's a lot easier to track down
all the changes rather than having to go through
the e-mail; you know, dig through all the
e-mail of a number of different systems or
even leases, anything like that. The other
thing that it needs is an authoritative conversation
model because especially with development
applications you really, really need to know
who said what and when. Now, in my local government
area, we recently--well, a couple of years
ago, we had a controversy because one of the
town planners was--how, shall we say, providing
extra services to one of the developers. Now,
we wouldn't be--in order for them to track
down that problem they've had to troll through
a hell of a lot of stuff. Whereas with the
Wave conversation model you can see exactly
when things were said, exactly what changes
were made to development applications or to
the notes around them without having to try
and troll through e-mails or even figure out
whether this e-mail is being faked or the
e-mail has been modified in some way. The
other thing is--I mean, Gov2.0 is a buzzword
that get thrown around a lot. I mean basically
for me, it means open government. The idea
that the information of the government needs
to be out there for the public to see and
that is easy to go through and Wave enables
this. Its authoritative conversation model
says, "These are the changes that were made
by whom," which is a really essential part
Gov2. 0. It means that it's easy to read.
The threads are there. You can read them without
having to worry about whether they were, you
know, top, bottom, middle posting and so it's
not that hard to actually read them. The protocols
are open. Federation protocols are open. Client-server
protocols are open. Anybody can--the formats,
the delta's formats are open. Anybody can
come back to this, say in ten year's time,
and build--if they need to have a look at
a thread and build something that will be
able to read it without having to rely on
a third party, which may have gone bust in
the meantime. Wave can be extended through
robots, gadgets and so on. We can link in
to other systems and start bringing them into
this open system. In local government in Australia,
every document is tracked so it goes into
a document storage system. Now through extending,
say, a Wave in a Box system or whichever--or
Pulse, or Vibe or whatever, we can now all
of a sudden link in to that system, pull the
documents into a wave conversation and actually
start working with them. The other thing it
does is in agendas apart of trust, okay? If
people know that their changes are being--their
changes are being noted, they know that things
will be kept, they're not going to start screwing
around. Well, they might. I mean, we're talking
about people. But we do know that they change--if
they do start screwing around, it'll be a
lot easier to find out where they screwed
around and actually go back and try and fix
it. So, really, Wave is the next step in open--opening
up government and it really helps deal with
a lot of the issues that e-mail has actually
managed to hide. And that's it. That's all
I can come up with in jetlag brain. Any questions?
Yes?
>> I just want to make a comment. I specialize
on public records access [INDISTICT] and this
is great coming from the [INDISTINCT] but
the reality is people who are on the inside,
they don't want these things to be exposed.
A lot of people will, you know, [INDISTINCT]
telephone and talk somebody to call in to
say something.
>> Oh, there's no--there's no doubt that Wave's
not going to able to capture everything. I
mean the water cooler's always going to be
where, you know, the little brown paper bag
might be passed around, but it does go some
way to fixing the e-mail problem. Now, e-mails
can be faked, e-mails can be--I mean, we had
a controversy in Australia a few years ago
where a public servant in our Treasury Department
was working for the opposition party and he
started sending fake e-mails out, right? It
was--if you ever get a chance, look up a guy
called Godwin Grech. But what he did was he
sent out these e-mails implicating our Prime
Minister at that day in a deal with a car
dealer in his home, in his electorate at home.
Now, these were fake. But the opposition grabbed
these and said, "Look at this, we've got a--we've
got this." And then, you know, all of the
sudden there's egg all over their face. With
Wave you can't do that. You know, you can't
fake a Wave in a way that you can an e-mail.
So it's that sort of, you know, we're stopping
up those holes which e-mail has. I mean, I'm
not saying that Wave's perfect by any means
but it's a lot better than the one we've got.
Anything else? Cool. Thank you very much.
. Now, these were fake. But the opposition
grabbed these and said, "Look at this, we've
got a--we've got this." And then, you know,
all of the sudden there's egg all over their
face. With Wave you can't do that. You know,
you can't fake a Wave in a way that you can
an e-mail. So it's that sort of, you know,
we're stopping up those holes which e-mail
has. I mean, I'm not saying that Wave's perf